Right. I get off the veins you bring me back around to your way of the track. You should like a recording there.
If you want to. All right from the very beginning it all goes on tightly around there.
So I've been trying to dig up a few more possible very strange reactions even the slightest thought one guy over thirty
years he's not telling what was going on.
Oh is he still worth anything and where the thing he said but my voice is written down here.
Here's a date even checked up with a guy for thirty years.
He's got one sister lives in cars
but he knows all except So I said this is not a minute it gives us that here with the Larry. These night talk shows.
I do want to give us just probably out of the box that yeah every night of the third in the closet
when they are not that far in is in the flip
and I think we've I mean we've had a number of people who were quite worried about about the response of the night
and it's enormous. And it's all good. So it's all going into the building.
You brought it up are much describe replies from winds and Bill's describing time yeah this is what you're up for
and we had that one loves his quite well known around town I guess. And I mean lots of people.
And he was terrified and he kept saying you have to just take.
So we turned it off and then he said Oh that's all right.
And then we start again you know and maybe his friend was sitting there saying something.
What was he naming
but now that's the only possible is how you know I mean he's I mean it's not something I don't think I don't get one
types of Woodstock the type you see how they do that even with a day without their permission.
You know it's strange but I can understand them in one way not really
and have what's the hardest I would manage to somebody who is well into their seventy's.
Well I'm going to bring a friend.
That's a bit of a state where you have somebody you know somebody knows you know the best coffee connection
but he's well into his eighty's and still going out weeks ago saying you know he would really go back to
and they would be very very accurately ready that you know you do you know with any sort of awareness of the sort of
action. Plenty of pressure before. He just wants to talk about it on the fringe of conversation.
He's dropped a lot of stories.
There's not a made in the seventy's
and you quite a bit about that this is I tell you that college they confirmed what I got from a very awkward around
calls you know something you can almost get that used to pass. You know you know what the hell is no. I've never could.
I mean I was there wasn't a foot in the lake to me to think about
but I want to get out of here context to the logical stuff you feel some of the stuff this might be real if you're
going to assess. You know what I have to say I think what I saw was a crazed or unimpressed.
I was going to give a little family background to put this into perspective their influence will help to begin with I
was adopted
and the guys there are born in twenty three there was a white list of children not exactly the adoption was not popular
in large mother referring to my daughter is now out of whack in regard.
Right now because in almost all of the natural mothers It just appears the white guy has a lot of affection goes back
to child.
But there was no attempt in those days to match that idea of what they do a taped
and that physically a little bit of background noise
and even the very early days of the time that they will take their reactions. But very successful family.
But it was now it said there was a long waiting list. I think it's done enough start. And that's the worst.
That I wasn't physically Robert was. But it will be a long succession of different sizes. As well fed will get there.
Yeah right. But God does. What damage that would do things like that. But.
As a result I grew up with it but I was much brought to the very beginning there was resentment because they married.
Up to that point their. Things their clothes when they took them back to. The family. Actually.
Don't do it then you get caught. Well. She was a person which is very strong. Very very soft. And I was watching.
Very strong. Not broad. But he had three of the name of religion in his Christian.
You want to start just just keep going. I think our next story right.
And this is a narrative that I read Life as an American value and that is that. This writer avoided one of at a time.
But the end result of this very very let's say restricted top it up bringing that first diet back.
I found almost impossible state of the share that was just right. More than this back. Stay there is no I don't.
It was a there was a guy that was just really there because even previous to that I was not the right one for pissing
in public life but with the movies of wifely and the hurt that I want to do this.
This was just too late
and even using the i've told it's it was excruciating down this place they had saw it was that night so I sit there
looking across to the other one was. This is Are you OK.
This time but at the office there are so that I still couldn't get a wife because I don't know what I was in school
when the war. Yeah six day like whether it's a little pill that we have a good time which is just sort of all.
That fish and bread.
After that had no one's home one which is the place where I think most of this is that why it was they said it was
absolutely.
It's the right thing to label the guy for siting in this stuff is because I was never a place you know that place
and I didn't look at it said I and they refuse the Green Day But I think their eyes.
There was twenty one and they used to say shout.
We had no idea at this point the shining of the cache I didn't put a lot of fights for kids here the dream was a ladder
stile about to break something else but they knew I was wrong because all for their image so that I grew up the term
and to do nothing that I see right there out there at all that we don't know right.
Teligent I wouldn't want to that is a place you know that we can have common sense you know since you have none.
So I had about a week. The wife back on the law and crossed out.
Used to come in the city and what it was was it in the by rotten cross between two out.
Still a lot of this particular point in the world history is not so we were put there wife
and the catch was I to my game a while back
and I was trying to say there was nobody in large groups that stuff like that.
So I was only about the studio
and I think the second time we went to say just there we went up to the OP I was a diver.
This is the fish to it he had been in Wichita and didn't like any impression on the thinking back of my youth.
There was a resistance saying so even then California or San Francisco I was told.
Anyway he said to come on Sunday that fronted up the box with Texas dry
and then six thirty to the South Street second in the light.
Yes to go on this or that stuff
but it's my eyes to see that there's a something like the region here stays with data another area to look there is the
mind and the leaning on the best looking day
and remember feeling this something was touching what I could still hear something sort of living ever so slightly
against my very very cautiously to my head young Americans are very proud of the prejudice.
They're very delicately that it was very crowded. It's hard to to be pretty and I tried desperately to include it.
So I still had it which is only taught C.
Well you know Wolf and that is that this is so low that even then I don't think you guys hear it like radios yet.
I think the only thing they don't stride with the list.
They're a strong list but if San Francisco guide that I was doing something that for so. Was there in Sydney today.
You know the first day or so if it was to be fundraising something like grab the title.
Yes we don't do this in the act but it was all fun day. It wasn't serious.
It's a real trial like the sort of thing I do.
Number one creatively answer how we got a while have lost looking out for the real one on the front office.
This could be recognizable as the southern suburbs. I think that's me and. Trey's drives.
Dave to series one he was part of it was a dozen friends down in the cellar with a truck.
It was the one we all judge whether there's one particular race black which think it is fighting the Alpha does this
matter a little when they're ready young host Don't do this don't do this limited to get a good life
and there was no car in the garage.
This is a highly paid for right and the right one quite like one or two more the whole thing.
So I got it all drive south saw the highway bridge ways on that way to pay to live within the hour now.
Is it on SR says he's still in this black outfit. You know I had to say that hat.
There was that big long black clouds everything.
It's like dealing with Laddie and he said what does he do when he got to be we going to change at comes to town
and he's sitting at the front here of.
We're all just about to do except run out why are you guys I have a great captive tall guy because this love like air
comes that with it's one of the silly six that that I had dropped it was there.
I've never saw your face like the three actually just took their eyes
but they offered because shot as he didn't realize it was drugs or things because he has these voices
but if you are going to do it.
With the dross like these are quite private but I think that the war in the drags that the time is usually
when the Irish
or the Kiwis is like My Lai rant alone in forty seven lighters that we want to see you know where they're not in Sydney
but it isn't so easy to use that very profession as if anything that their forces produce story in their stride
or their merry way that we've done that actually started really well but the key ways from here.
Considering the size of the tundra and there's always been that twenty years behind us and if anything this time
and social acceptance and rate of one of those there was a whole variety show.
Yes you had the miles in uniform you had drag queens. Mary singers. It was a real draw to the drug war rooms.
Yeah I mean except. Let me try and it was a raft of it. I know how I thought how is he thought. Yes that.
Yet another service that date serious I did Jodi.
But the drag queen tonight I always took a week off of the year and there's a lot back
and saw a group right here right there as to what the person that I was discussing this with this friend last night
and he is tonight dragged to his little Caylee to some of the interesting.
They're trying to tell you what happened to the dressing then I mean to not sign that said off I think a lot of
attention a lot of paid to him but not long after that he was going to parties
and so are some of the most serious really intentional and they had to type taxis right here to get to
and from the five because if I was out for the Jewish boy the best of that stuff probably pre-war too probably prevail
in the truck here who actually bought it. If they are doing what's right.
Here and all but I think they were pretty tight and I would say that the guys are nothing.
It was a time
when all of us right up in the fifty's who live this way to get us so these little things for the hard hat.
She couldn't sit so the only way to get this far right supposed steady I guess I got the racist way to get it
and that it was the one who had a lot of the hair. She died that I was facing a fall and three different ways of life.
He was going to be the man had it as you build and they still had when they stood on top of this poor innocent page.
After. What. Thought our thoughts our thoughts. Thought I thought.